we have a top rated poll a rated poll
which says that Trump would crush Biden
in 2024 and DeSantis would crush Biden
in 2024 we're going to look at the poll
many of my right-wing friends wrote to
me over the weekend and said David you
will never cover this poll
does that sound like me does that sound
like something I would do just ignore a
poll because the numbers don't coincide
with I guess what I would like the
numbers to say which I would like the
numbers to say nobody's going to be so
stupid that they're going to fall for
voting for Trump again that's what I
would like the numbers to say many of
the numbers don't say that so let's look
at this this new poll and then look at
some caveats Biden faces broad negative
ratings at the start of campaign post
ABC poll finds and indeed we don't have
to look at every aspect of the poll
but when we look at the 538
um a compilation of recent polls and
please there's these people in the
audience who will write to me and say
David why do you use left wing 538 to
look at polls 538 isn't doing their own
polls 5 38 just Aggregates polls so you
can look at the polls and judge for
yourself the deal with the polls okay
ABC News Washington Post poll among
registered voters
Biden losing to DeSantis by six that is
no longer a statistical Dead Heat there
is a caveat and I'll get to it in a
moment among all adults DeSantis leading
Biden by even more seven
what about Biden versus Trump well among
registered voters Trump leads Biden by
six the exact same lead that DeSantis
has and then if you look Instead at all
adults rather than just registered
voters Trump leads Biden by seven the
exact same lead that Ron DeSantis has
over Biden so anytime we get one poll we
usually want to do three things actually
listen it let's be thorough okay it's a
Monday we can be a little more thorough
we want to do four things number one is
this a well-rated poll
or is this a toilet trash pole this is a
this is a well-rated pole a rating ABC
News Washington poll generally speaking
these polls are trustworthy second
question is there something about the
timing of what is being asked about that
would make all polling about this
question less accurate well I don't know
the answer to that you can make the case
it's too early to do general election
polling because it's only May of the
year before but the the important thing
is if it's too early it's equally too
early for any pollsters so we can
compare this poll to other polls that's
the second question is there something
about the timing or in particular that
would make this a bad time to ask about
this number three are there many
undecideds where you have a lot of
blanks in the polling and the answer is
in this poll we do when DeSantis leads
Biden 44-38 that means 18 of people uh
did not choose either of them they
either said unsure neither don't know
too early to say that's a lot of people
because the the margin is only six so
when 18 aren't even there that's a
that's a question and then with Biden
Trump 16 aren't in there 39.45 you've
got 16 percent of the electorate these
elections come down to somewhere between
one and Five Points in general so yes
that is a big big caveat a lot of people
were not forced into making a choice
here they could say I'm just not sure
yet I don't know someone else and then
the fourth question in general when we
look at polling is
are these polls is this poll an outlier
compared to others and it sort of is if
you look at other polling for example
the b-plus rated yougov poll that was
done just a day before the one I just
told you about that one has Biden
leading DeSantis and Biden tied with
Trump
so the most important message here is
whatever your view on whether you gov
should be a B plus or a B minus poll or
whether the ABC News poll was you know
done at 3am and people were too tired to
respond accurately like whatever you
want to come up with with any of these
polls the message here needs to be it is
not at all obvious
that Joe Biden can defeat DeSantis or
Trump in reelection that's what we need
to be screaming from the rooftops and
that needs to be the message now one bit
of good news from this
is that desantis's numbers against Biden
are good and let me tell you why that's
good news I'll explain what I mean
DeSantis has been crumbling in
Republican primary polls and he had this
bizarre you know where he was asked a
question and he he grinned and was like
a bobble head he was massively triggered
when asked about Trump recently and
we'll have more clips of DeSantis later
today he just doesn't seem to be able to
handle it Republican donors are bailing
on DeSantis billionaires saying this guy
doesn't have what it takes
and so DeSantis it's not clear whether
DeSantis will or won't announce
I believe it is better for the eventual
Democratic nominee likely Joe Biden for
DeSantis and Trump to have a really long
and a really ugly primary I believe that
that will weaken them I don't believe
this well whoever comes out will be
stronger because of the fight no I
believe that many will be turned off by
how ugly DeSantis V Trump is likely to
get and hopefully DeSantis will be
encouraged to run even if he's not doing
so well in the Republican primary polls
because he sees hey if somehow I could
get on the ballot in November of 24 I
have a really good shot at defeating Joe
Biden his ego may not allow him to get
away from running when he sees those
poll results that's the one good bit of
news I can find of them the really
disturbing news is this is a country
who is so disconnected from fact
empiricism Common Sense reality sanity
to some degree that they genuinely might
there's tens of millions of people who
if they get the chance they'll put Trump
in the Oval Office or DeSantis in the
Oval Office and that should really scare
us we'll have all of these stories on
our YouTube channel go to youtube.com
forward slash the David Pacman show help
us get to 2 million subscribers on
YouTube we'll take a quick break and be
right back one of our sponsors is Helix
sleep I have been sleeping on a helix
mattress at home for years now I
couldn't be more happy with it I
recommend it to everybody the other day
even though she's not allowed in the big
bed I put my baby daughter on the
mattress and even she loved it Helix
sleep is the premium mattress brand
offering tailored mattresses based on
your unique sleep preferences take the
Helix sleep quiz it asks you about your
body type your sleeping position Edition
do you get hot at night do you have back
pain and then Helix will match you with
the mattress that's perfect for you most
people don't know where to begin when
shopping for a mattress including me
Helix makes it simple and less risky
because you know you're getting a
mattress that fits your needs it ships
free you can try it for a hundred nights
to see if you like it and it comes with
a 10 or 15 year warranty unlike many
mattress companies all Helix mattresses
are made in the USA by a skilled
production team so you are supporting
good jobs Helix sleep is giving my
audience up to 20 percent off plus two
free pillows what other mattress company
is going to give you 20 off go to
helixsleep.com Pacman the link is down
below